you know who's the the the one blue dog
Democrat who is it my hero John fedman
yeah I guess he's had the craziest 2023
story AR I I called I I contribute to
his campaign I I spotted this guy from a
mile away you can't miss him there were
funny memes of YouTube thumbnail the
meme is a YouTube th thumbnail of fedman
saying why I left the
left but in all seriousness fed people
are like how did you predict this guy so
so well John fedman and he is one of
these old school lefties who think the
point of government is to help people
been screwed over by the system whether
it's food stamps or whatever who thinks
politics can be honorable and that
politicians shouldn't be put themselves
on a pedestal and are just like someone
trying to make the world a better place
so that old school Democrat stuff which
is almost kind of in late 60s that's him
so when people are surprised that he's
taking these stances I'm like it makes
perfect sense that he call it corruption
because in his point government is
something that can be used to help
people who have been screwed over and if
that argument is one that I don't hate
and I say this as an anarchist